Thank you.
I'm just going to wait a few minutes to see.
And again, it's not because anyone is more important than you.
It's because I repeat myself enough as it is.
You know, it's a problem in real life as well as on X.
I'm just going to wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes.
I'm just going to wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes to see if I can't wait a few minutes.
Thank you.
More than likely, nobody else will.
Right now there are a number of spaces running and some of them have more than a hundred people and the way that people determine, um, you know, whether it's, you know, uh, whether it makes sense or not the way people determine how they choose spaces is obviously how many people are already watching.
So I remember for a while it was this thing in, uh, maybe it still is with the UFO X people where they would, um, instead of waiting like five minutes or 10 minutes to see if anyone would show up, they'll, uh,
they'll post up, you probably had this, I know you mostly interested in astrology, but you, you may have seen it.
Um, you're going to space and they're quiet.
No one will be talking and there's 30 or 40 people in the space because they, um, they want to wait until they hit like a critical mass.
I don't know what number they would use, uh, before they start the space.
And that makes sense from, uh, like not repeating oneself, but they're not really, they don't really have anything to say.
Right.
Like it's, it's chat, it's conversation, which is, which is fine.
I mean, I like to talk to people.
Um, you know, I always, I would be a lot better with spaces if I had people come up and talk.
Um, because it, it, it, much more effective as a communicator when I can break it up with a little, uh, interaction.
So I get that, uh, it's not being critical of them, but what I'm saying is that the regular spaces crowd is, you know,
there's no way they're going to, uh, at nine 20 on a Saturday night, they're going to look and, you know, see the, uh,
basically UFO X is a giant high school drama club.
So I always think of it and I have to stop myself and try to translate, say UFO X,
because the first thing that will pop into my mind is like the drama club.
Um, anyhow.
Yeah.
So they're all doing that thing.
I want to just, um, get this recorded so that I can say like, I can say that I, you know,
I have one of the reasons that we, well, we, uh, um, maybe more going to come back.
One of the reasons that, um, to run something like this is to have a recorded, um, or a record
right of a contemporaneous record of giving your opinion and, um, of your ideas.
There's no way really in the, in like the influencer society, right?
There's no way to stop people from upstaging him.
Uh, somebody who's a exploitative, a successful influencer, um,
you know, we'll, uh, hey, Sinan, well, because we're talking, we're going to talk about an
successful exploitative influencer, right?
Because Dan, um, lurks.
He used to talk to people.
He stopped talking to people on X, but he still lurks on X in order to get his material and
his insights.
Um, and he did admit, uh, inadvertently in the video, uh, that he just made to doing
that.
Um, so yeah, there's no way if you get someone who's, who's successful at marketing themselves,
they got 85,000, 185,000 followers.
Um, and, and you don't write, and you can say something a hundred times.
Like you can be the first to, I can give you, I could probably, if you gave me a couple of
minutes, write out 20 or 30, uh, a list of 20 or 30 things over the last three years that
I've been the first, as far as I can find, um, person to talk about online, right?
Related to astrology or remote viewing.
It doesn't, you know, all that I'm doing is really giving ideas to people who have larger
platforms who then go forward to profit from those ideas.
But at least as time goes on, I can say, look, you know, they, they say things successfully,
they, they profit from them, but they're always saying things six months after I say them.
Right.
And it won't make a big difference with the general population, but it will make a difference
with some people.
Right.
And those are the people I'm trying to reach.
I'm trying to reach people specifically who are looking to talk to me.
Right.
Um, and yeah, I'm never going to be, I'm never going to have a hundred thousand followers.
I, I wouldn't, I, I, I think if once is a very exploitative people and I, I think that everyone
who listens to me, like everyone who follows me on X, I, I assume as a, as a smart person,
I do.
Um, but it's a numbers game.
You get to a certain number of followers and your average follower, isn't going to be,
they're not going to have much going on, which is fine.
I guess I don't have much going on, but what I'm saying is, is that it's not like, um, I
don't necessarily think people should be proud by saying like, I'm followed by 200,000 people.
If they say they're followed by 200,000 people, I would be like, well, you know, I'm followed
by a thousand, but it's a thousand good ones.
That's the way I look at it, right.
As opposed to a 200,000 people, maybe a hundred thousand, aren't that great.
So, uh, what happened is, um, right before I was going to start my earlier space, which
was on, um, comparing the comparing, contrasting the major, um, Western astrological transit for
this year, the major Vedic astrological transit for this year.
So I wanted to say like, what is the, the most notable event from each system and how
do they compare and contrast and how do they fit together?
Cause they're very different, but they, oftentimes we started from places, but then we come back
to the same place in our final interpretation, which is really amazing, but it's very, it happens
very consistently.
Three minutes before the space, I see that Dan Waits of world astrology report has put up
a new Astro RV video.
Now, ostensibly, although Morgan and I did the Astro RV project and published it, you
know, widely publicized it in the RV world, ostensibly other people who do it claim that
they've never heard of it.
Okay.
That's fine.
Uh, getting people to, the more people who do, who run Astro RV projects, the more interested
other people are going to be in running Astro RV projects.
Even if I'm not saying people are, but even if, were they trying to be exploitative, if
our goal is popularizing the principles, then we really can't lose, even if other people
are profiting to a much greater degree.
And it's a proven thing that, um, although we have, you know, until, although IU has great
remote viewers and I'm frankly a better astrologer than Dan Waits, um, just out of experience.
He may be a more knowledgeable astrologer, but he doesn't, the experience makes a difference
in the interpretation.
Um, we would do a better job, but that's, that's hypothetical.
It's imaginary because, uh, we never got it together.
Right.
And I, I, I can't be in control of what other people do.
So, um, if I'm working with someone who isn't very productive or isn't very motivated or is
kind of stuck in life.
Right.
So that, that, that is a reflection on my effectiveness as well.
So I can't say that Dan isn't more effective.
I can say because he's, in my opinion, an exploitative influencer, I wouldn't see him as, well, I have
talked to him online a few times before he stopped talking to people online or like limited his,
the people he would talk to.
Um, they weren't bad conversations naturally, necessarily, but they, uh, he wasn't as respectful
as he should have been.
And, and I believe he appropriated some information.
That's my personal belief.
And again, you know, he's a much bigger account than I am.
So people might not believe it.
Um, but that's fine.
That's why you, if you talk, if you tell someone something, then they, and they use it.
That's, that's fine.
Anyhow, um, he's, he's more effective at getting the information out.
By far.
And, uh, you know, I'll never be an influencer, but if I was, I wouldn't be as good at it as
he is.
Um, he's got the influencer thing down probably because he's a writer.
So he put out a video on, um, the major event in April.
And that, that was the task.
The task was, um, the major event associated with the conjunction of Mars and Saturn on April
19th of this year.
Um, right now we're going through a, uh, we were just recently, uh, these fucking cats,
man, in route, dude.
Okay.
Um, we, we recently, uh, entered the active phase of the Saturn Neptune conjunction.
We've actually, um, sort of, it's almost like an initiation, right?
So like the events related to that conjunction have been initiated and now it's sort of playing
out.
From his perspective, what he's looking for as a mundane astrologer is specific dates.
People associate predictions with dates and that's not really, that's not really, astrology is
not really about predicting dates, but about predicting periods of time, right?
Dates are far less, um, actionable than periods of time.
Um, you know, if you say it's this one day and, and you, you're going to take, you're going
to shape everything around that day and take action.
People are much less likely to be effective.
Um, but also it's very difficult to predict events accurately to the day, most of the time with
astrology.
So you lose people, people will stop, um, listening to what you have to say.
And also, um, you know, people can be set up in a situation where they think they're in
the, like a safe zone, they're in the clear and then get blindsided by the event, um, happening
at a later time because of a combination of the planets involved.
Um, complicating factors, et cetera.
So it's at least give different dates.
You never want to focus on one date.
Uh, he looks for mundane transits.
So he's looking at, um, things just happening in the sky.
Um, and he should, in my opinion, be focused on the Saturn-Neptune conjunction at zero degrees
areas.
He never has been.
He's always focused on less notable mundane transits.
That seemed very important to him, um, because they have, uh, a record of predicting events
on exact days.
Um, anyhow, so he's looking at April 19th.
That was the task.
And he did this thing again.
He does this like, um, any competent astrologer thing.
He's like, uh, you know, look at, uh, look at the events related to April 19th that any competent
mundane astrology would interpret as related to the day.
The problem with that is number one, it presumes that he's a competent mundane astrologer.
He's, he's very knowledgeable.
I don't know if he's a competent mundane astrologer experience wise.
He whiffed the date, right?
We did this last August.
This is the second time that looking at the same information, the second time the, the dating
and the tasking hasn't been ideal.
In my opinion, it's better this time.
He's definitely competent astrologer.
Um, but for what he's trying to do, I don't know if he is, to be honest.
Um, but very knowledgeable and he will be right.
He's five years in, um, as are the remote viewers he, um, he worked with.
And when you're five years in, that's when you radically overestimate your, uh, your knowledge
and competence.
Um, so what they looked at.
It was, uh, events related to that day.
I think they made a mistake.
I'm going to start off and say my, my immediate first reaction to seeing the video is I think
they made a mistake.
I think the day they should be looking at the most, this is my opinion.
And I could be proven wrong on this, right?
Like I'm far from perfect.
Uh, we're talking about like within a month, right?
Um, so I'm not going to like take it personally.
If April 19th is the day and not April 9th or 10th, I would look at April 9th or 10th.
Um, this is a principle that seems to elude him.
Um, Mars will activate the larger transit on that day.
So what happens is, uh, Mars will come around the Zodiac and when it crosses zero degrees Aries,
it will activate the major transit that recently occurred at zero degrees Aries.
Now there's a, a limitation on that time-wise, um, and you would measure it not in, in the
period of time, but the number of degrees, right?
So I would say if both Saturn and Neptune were more than five degrees away from the point
of the conjunction, when Mars got there, then I would not expect an event.
Uh, Saturn itself is, uh, less than two degrees or will be right around two degrees from the
exact degree of the conjunction.
So it will still be within orb.
So we would expect that when Mars crosses that point, there will be a major event.
We would also look at it from, look at like confirming data.
So like this thing with Chris Bledsoe, I'm not a Bledsoe guy and I don't think he understood
what he was told.
And I don't necessarily think that whatever communicated with him was on the level.
There might be some deception there.
Um, however, the association that he had with Easter, right?
There are two Easter's.
So the Easter that we are celebrating tomorrow is not, um, the traditional Easter.
The traditional Easter is going to be, you know, we're going to celebrate that on the 12th
because the Orthodox Easter is celebrated in the Julian calendar.
The calendar was changed.
Um, the way the Catholic church determines Easter is to look at, um, is to look at Passover
because Passover was the, you know, was the, the date of the crucifixion and, um, and then
celebrate the next Sunday from Passover.
Uh, that's, I don't think that, I mean, the, the Orthodox does the same thing, but they use
the Julian calendar.
So, uh, it's usually a week off and growing up, um, my mother's side of the family was
Greek and my father's side of the family was, uh, or they are Greek Orthodox and my father's
side was Catholic.
So we would celebrate both Easter's.
The Greek Easter was far more enjoyable in my opinion.
Um, and I'll be running a space next Sunday, uh, for coffee talk.
If anyone wants to have traditional coffee talk, because unfortunately I no longer have
a Greek family close enough to me that I can have, um, Greek Easter coffee talk.
But I, I am feeling sentimental and remembering my, my family.
So I, if anyone is around on that, that, um, Sunday, not necessarily anyone who's here
right now, but just, I'll have a space at that time to talk about, I don't know, whatever.
So, uh, I would look at the 9th or 10th of April as opposed to the 19th.
However, I have heard the, I've heard psychics mentioned April 20th, uh, as a potential date
for some sort of event.
So they may well hit the, the target.
Um, they have five remote viewers.
Uh, the first remote viewer, a male remote viewer.
Um, I don't think they hit the targets very well, but I think combined together, you can
put together a case that they were on target.
The first remote viewer saw an explosive event on a building that was under construction.
They saw some sort of airstrike and he suspected that the event could be in Taipei or in somewhere
in Taiwan, um, or in China.
Uh, Dan commented on it and suggested that perhaps Tehran, Dan has a fixation on Tehran,
which proved to be, look, when we're fighting the war in Iran, right?
He was fixated on it, but he, you know, give him his due.
Like the war in Iran is a big thing now.
We all thought it would be, but I understand his fixation.
So, um, again, like I, in life, we're probably not on the same team.
I think enemy might be a strong term, right?
But adversarial position in life.
Um, not that I'm his equal, obviously, uh, as far as influence is concerned, but I'm still
going to give him his due.
Uh, as soon as we heard this earlier, Bark Like a Duck was there, Melissa was there, saying
and you weren't there, but you would have been on it too.
As soon as, um, Bark Like told me that they had a burning tower and he asked me, didn't
Morgan and Dan have, um, a tower explosion in some of their material?
They did.
And, uh, that was the session data.
They don't like talking about it.
It's one of the sessions they don't like talking about very much.
They're going to be coaxed, but the, the targeting information, I'm not going to, I don't have
it exactly, but basically they were looking at the next major U S, um, nine 11 type disaster.
Basically, uh, that's a paraphrase.
It's not the exact target.
Um, and they saw a tower, um, that had been attacked.
They saw protesters around the tower.
They saw some sort of, um, military, um, research going on in the tower and that.
Um, that may be a hit, but regardless of what happens, we're never going to know if there
was military research in the towers involved.
Anyhow, they saw it on the U S West coast.
Dan brings this up at the end of his video.
So I'm not going to say like, he had no idea.
He, he does bring this up at the end of his video that there has been scuttlebutt about,
um, well, there've been official warnings about, um, Iranian drone strikes in Los Angeles,
potentially, and I'm not saying it's true.
I'm not saying it's going to happen.
I'm saying like, that's, that's been in the news as like a potential threat.
Um, in Los Angeles, it makes sense.
Cause it's close enough to the Mexican border that, um, something could be smuggled over
right.
Um, through the tunnels and, um, you know, San Diego or Los Angeles would make more sense
than like a Midwestern city.
So Dan did bring that up at the end of the video.
That's the first thing that I heard as soon as, uh, or I thought of as soon as Mark talked
to me about it.
Um, and that's definitely so that the intuitive underground material doesn't single out Los
Angeles, but it's a West coast city.
I think it's implied, but it could be, um, San Francisco, uh, as well, maybe Seattle, but
I think they, they were talking California.
Um, so that does exist and that's some years old.
Um, I think it probably goes back three or four years that, that session data, but I'm
not positive on that.
I could be, I could be wrong.
Um, I'm not actively talking to Morgan right now, not of my own, um, you know, he's tired
of my shit or whatever.
Uh, so I couldn't check before this, um, or maybe he's just preoccupied.
Sometimes people will just be occupied with life, right?
The second viewer, uh, was a woman or is a woman or 2026.
So I shouldn't say that.
I don't know how they identify, but they appear to be a woman.
Um, they saw a deep impact event.
Um, that's the term they used like the movie deep impact.
Um, they, they saw something going on in space, their description reminded me of independence
day.
And if I were the analyst, um, I would suspect analytical overlay, uh, was involved in, in
her session because what she described sounded very similar to, um, the UFOs destroying the
buildings in independence day where they shot like a beam of light down at the same time.
She was talking about that happening in space.
So at first I thought she was talking about from space.
Then she was talking about in space.
But what is notable, I think from her session is that she saw a little fragments of glowing
DNA floating around.
So she's saying like an energy weapon was used, something blows up.
And then there's this mutated DNA floating around that she's seeing as like part of some
kind of weapon.
I don't think she's on target with that.
She might be.
If I were the analyst for that session, I would suspect she's talking about, um, nuclear,
uh, fallout of some kind, um, cesium or something because, uh, the glowing, uh, floating DNA,
um, immediately reminded me of like how we envision, uh, radiac, radiation is glowing, radioactive particles
is glowing and radioactive particles have an effect on DNA.
So as an analyst, I would immediately think potential radioactive, um, fallout of some kind
related to the incident, whatever incident she's talking about.
Um, what occurred to me as she was talking, cause we've had all these meteorites, right?
In Texas.
Um, there was some speculation, I think in this, in this video, just briefly that perhaps something
from space fell and hit a building.
That's possible.
I would also point out that they're looking at, um, news information, the most notable event
at the time.
It's not unusual to get two results back.
This could be related.
It could be unrelated.
They're looking at April 19th.
However, the tasking information is, um, the conjunction of Mars and Saturn.
Okay.
That's very close to the conjunction of Mars and the Neptune Saturn conjunction, like the,
the Mars crossing over that, that degree.
The reason that's important is, um, we have a capsule, right?
Supposedly we've got people flying around, flying to the moon.
Now, no one talks about it.
No one thinks about it because the world is so fucked up.
The world is so, excuse my language, right?
The world is so crazy right now that we have astronauts on the way to the moon and no one
cares.
And it should be like galvanizing, right?
It should be riveting to everyone around the world.
Um, it's like, it is secondhand news.
It's like, we're all worried about other stuff.
We're not worried about the astronauts and their failing toilets, which is like the biggest
story, right?
So far is that their toilet keeps messing up.
And that's, if you think about it, that's a pretty, if they are up there in a bucket flying
towards the moon and the, the toilet keeps breaking, like that's a disaster.
And apparently it, it stinks up there.
That's not me saying that that's, that's the news today is that they, one of the astronauts
was like, man, it's, it really stinks in this capsule because that busted toilet.
It's like being stuck in an outhouse flying through space.
So some kind of destruction involving an object in space, right?
Energetic destruction that immediately brought to my mind the, the, uh, the, the, the astronauts
going to the moon.
It didn't come up in the video.
And the reason it didn't come up in the video is because they're looking at the 19th.
Dan doesn't recognize that the 9th or 10th is much more likely date for a, a major global
event.
This could be two events.
This could be an event around the 19th and an event on the 9th or 10th.
Um, they would both be applicable to the targeting data as it was not written as concisely as it
should have been.
In my opinion, the third viewer had a coastal.
Coastal city, sub-Saharan, at least we're on, we're on the coast now, right?
So we've got two people talking about coastal cities.
They're talking about sub-Saharan that immediately like Los Angeles isn't sub-Saharan.
However, the environment is, is very like the analytical overlay can occur with words as well.
Right?
So they can have a word that's, it's not, or, or metaphors can come through.
So they can have like, um, like the environment could be Saharan without being the Sahara.
Right?
And Southern California is very, it's a, it's a desert.
Now I'm not saying that's the case, right?
So that would be dangerous.
If you were in the endless, you wouldn't want to, you wouldn't want to draw that conclusion
because that, that could be projection.
But based on this other evidence, I'm like, well, that's notable.
The fourth remote viewer had protesters on site.
They had protesters at the site of the explosion, which is exactly what came up in the intuitive
underground data.
They had someone being thrust forward in the role of, of leadership, which is something that
came through in the intuitive underground data.
The image of what was happening was very similar to the image from the intuitive underground
data of a West coast, um, a West coast 9-11 style event.
The fifth viewer was, uh, Josh, who is, although he only has five years as the most experienced
viewer of the group.
Um, he has, he's, he's legitimately, he's, I mean, I would follow him.
I don't categorize him.
He's not an enemy.
He's not an adversary, I should say.
Um, he's not necessarily a friend.
Uh, he can be friendly.
I don't know what his role will be in the future.
Um, obviously he gravitates.
He's a scene queen.
No offense, Josh, if you listen to this, he gravitates towards, you know, as many people
do towards the influences with a lot of friends and a lot of followers.
Okay.
It is what it is.
Uh, anyhow, he had a sky event.
Uh, someone was looking up and, and, and pointing.
He had Trump.
He's obsessed with Trump.
Trump comes up and everything for him.
So it's not my politics.
It's his politics.
He had Trump pointing a finger up to a sky event.
Um, and the world's watching it and being caught by surprise.
Of course, that brings to mind the lunar lander.
I mean, the lunar, it's not a lander.
I'm going to get grilled on this one.
The lunar capsule, whatever it is, it's flying around the moon right now.
Right.
That's exactly something that the whole world would be watching.
Um, it's something that if anything happened, people would be caught by surprise.
It is not something that would happen on April 19.
So they could be very, they could be on target and something happens around April 19th up in the sky, but they could also be off target.
And my analysis is correct.
And it would happen on the 9th of 10th, right?
But I could be wrong.
Uh, I'm just basing it.
I'm not a remote viewer myself.
I'm just basing on what I see.
So, um, he has life in a capsule.
Believe it or not.
Yeah.
In his session, he's got life in a capsule, but no one says, no one says the lunar, uh, capsule because the target dates is April 19.
So instead of questioning if this target was written correctly and are we on target, like no one thought to do that.
Including, and this is why, again, I know I'm, I'm putting this as like adversarial, but I don't think Dan Waite should be running after RV, uh, without any assistance because he's, he's, he's making mistakes.
And those mistakes are going to slow the adoption of the methodology.
Uh, and I think that's exploitative.
That's my opinion.
So life in a capsule, hell of the loft, some sort of AI, AI technology being involved.
Well, this screams lunar mission to me, but I could be wrong.
There could be another capsule in the sky full of life that involves Trump pointing out what's happening there that involves AI technology.
I doubt it, but we'll see.
Right.
And if I'm wrong, I'll be the first person to come on and say, I, I really screwed that one up.
Uh, what does he say?
Uh, yeah, there's a boom.
There's some sort of explosion.
Um, Trump reacts in some way on the, on the, with the news, the press, this is him.
Um, saying this one remote viewer, um, I can't read the next thing that I wrote.
Uh, the word is something.
Yeah.
So I, I wrote the word is, and then you've got like a, God only knows what I wrote here.
And then, uh, Oh, he had like, um, talking about a ship or a boat, believe it or not.
And a spirit in the sky.
So Josh Maitland's data to me, and I, he's probably the strongest remote viewer, the most experienced of the group.
They're not again, very experienced, but they could be very strong.
Clearly focuses on a ship, uh, a sky capsule, people in a capsule, AI related to a capsule.
Like, uh, I'm shocked that neither he nor Dan brought up the, the lunar mission.
I hope they're not right.
Or I hope my impression, I hope my impression, my interpretation, my analysis is incorrect.
Cause I don't want anything to happen with that mission.
Um, however, from the perspective of the Saturn Neptune conjunction as the governing transit for this period and for a long time in the future, we're looking at symbolism and, and events related to the collapse of civilization as it is right now.
Um, so, um, you know, not the extinction of civilization, but the collapse of the global system.
And that's not like, um, we all go back to our countries and everything is fine.
That's like a real traumatic, destructive event involving wars and, and famine and shortages.
So it's a real bad scene, right?
But it's not like the end of everything.
But if you're going to look at it, like what is one of the greatest symbols of modern civilization?
Like one of the greatest symbols of modern civilization, you know, led by the United States was the moon landing.
And regardless of whether you believe it's real or not, like that, that is top five, if not the number one image that people would relate to, um, to the peak of American civilization of the global empire.
There would be nothing more symbolic, nothing more Saturn conjunct Neptune, um, than if something were to happen.
With this trip, I don't, I don't, you know, it would be a, an image that would be a, a bookend to a period of time, right?
The beginning of the period of time would be the, we've landed on the moon or we made it to the moon.
The end of the period of time would be, we tried to head back to the moon and something happened.
So I certainly hope that's not the case, but it would definitely fit the astrology.
It's possible that, that my interpretation here is often whatever happens will be highly symbolic of the transit.
Uh, but not what I would expect.
That's definitely possible.
Um, Los Angeles, uh, like Taipei, China, Iran, all of their astrological charts are activated by the Saturn-Neptune conjunction.
They wouldn't be in the news right now if they, if they weren't.
Los Angeles's chart is also activated by the Saturn-Neptune conjunction.
However, the U.S. chart is, and, uh, he didn't mention this in the video, so if you watch the video, he omits the fact that the Saturn-Neptune conjunction happened at a point in the charts called the IC of the U.S. chart, the Sibley chart.
Um, if you look up the U.S. chart, you want to look for the Sibley chart.
That's debated, but not among serious astrologers.
Serious astrologers all accept the Sibley chart.
The IC is the homeland of a nation.
All right, so it's the physical land.
It means a different thing.
In your chart, it means your family.
Um, it means your family home.
It means, uh, if your family owned mines or had something going on underground that's very rare now, but it wasn't in the past, uh, it would, it would talk about, like, what's underground.
Your family roots, your family tree, and also the grave, because in the past, people were buried on their family property.
Well, that's what the fourth house means.
Uh, with a nation, the fourth house means the physical land of the nation itself.
So continental United States, um, okay, I got, uh, a message from Morgan.
I don't know what it means.
Uh, could be good, could be bad.
Probably bad because I've been on a roll lately.
But anyhow, I'm going to be positive.
So, um, the physical land of the nation.
So any type of disaster or, or crisis, um, that occurs to my mind, very likely to affect the U.S.
And, uh, if you remember the Columbia, not the, which was the one when I was young, when I was, oh, there was the Columbia and then there was another one, right?
There were two that blew up the second one.
So the challenger was when I was young and the Columbia blew up and like around the time of George Bush, right?
2004, 2003, and it blew up over Texas and they didn't want anyone touching any of the parts or material because it was radioactive or had chemicals, right?
There was like a radioactive, or there was a nuclear reactor.
There was some kind of chemical, whatever.
So they didn't want anyone touching that.
Again, I'm not saying this would happen.
However, hypothetically, if that thing, if there was a problem on re-entry, um, we could, we could be talking about missiles.
We could be talking about UFOs.
We could be talking about alien UFOs.
But if it's this thing, um, and something happens to it, then contamination as indicated by the other viewers.
And in other RV sessions from, from other groups, that is something that's possible.
Like it's possible that some sort of material would, would be released over the continental United States.
And at that point, it would be a national crisis.
Whether you look at the IU material, it's some sort of galvanizing national event.
You look at what this material is talking about.
It's a galvanizing national event.
If Iran is tied into the event or another country, it would certainly mobilize a greater percentage of the U.S. population to support a war than, than is currently the case.
Um, I don't go down the road of false flag.
Everything's a false flag, right?
Like when this, when, when the Navy deployed to Iran, there were remote viewers who were putting out videos saying, will there be a false flag?
Right.
But if you are in a Naval war and your Navy is actively attacking a country, and if they sink one of your ships, that's not a false flag.
Like everything is called a false flag.
It's nonsense.
That doesn't mean they don't exist, but like the definition is, is gone a little bit loose.
Right.
Um, so people speculating, or is this a false flag?
Like that's, that shouldn't be any, anyone's number one.
It's stupid to talk about, but, um, we're at war.
So, you know, there is a constant danger now of this type of retaliation.
It shouldn't be any speculation, like we're seeing a building blow up if it's in the United States and then it would have to be, is it some kind of fault?
No, it wouldn't.
Then, then, you know, it would, it would quite possibly be any of the, the nations involved, the one we're currently fighting or their allies, right?
Like that's, that's on the table.
Um, so I, I don't support that verbiage as well.
At the very end of the, of the video, Dan does say, by the way, one thing, and he talks about Los Angeles and he talks about, um, some of the stuff that's been publicized about Los Angeles online.
And this like recent, um, recent warning that there could be some sort of, uh, terrorist activity in Los Angeles.
Um, there is at least one remote viewer who's identified two possible events in Los Angeles.
Uh, and it's interesting that we're speculating that this material might refer to two events as opposed to one event, right?
It couldn't refer to something that happens in the sky and also something that happens to a bit, a building.
Obviously we don't hope none of this is true.
Um, they are talking about April 19th.
I think that will lull people into a false sense of security.
I would be highly concerned on the 9th or 10th, but let's see if nothing happens on the 9th or 10th.
Maybe it'll be the 19th, hopefully nothing happens.
This is, this type of prediction is the type of prediction where you always want to be wrong.
You don't ever want to be right.
And you want to, to, uh, give me a culpas, right?
I didn't, um, I'm not part of this Astro RV project, so it's not my predictions, right?
So people come back and say, you know, first of all, I'll be celebrating the fact nothing happens.
If it does, then people will come back and say your prediction failed.
It's, it'll be a double, you know, it'd be like you lose, lose situation.
You lose if it, if it happens, you lose, if it doesn't, cause it wasn't your prediction with someone else's prediction.
But I still accept that.
I will gladly be in a lose, lose situation of having people, um, accuse me of a, of a fake prediction or a false prediction or of not knowing what I'm talking about.
Whatever Dan waits in his team's prediction fails, if it doesn't happen, that's, that's a fair bargain for me.
I, I, I will accept that, um, this, these type of tragedies, the, they're terrible.
I was concerned about, uh, solar flares today or tomorrow.
Right.
And, um, as I've said in other spaces, like I'm always concerned every April 1st, because to me, that's the day that I would imagine enemies would be most likely to attack the U S.
Like some sort of a terrorist attack or something, um, because fewer people would respond to react.
They would think it was a joke.
Right.
Um, and that's what you want.
You want people to not respond.
So we made it past another April 1st.
Awesome.
I am, I'm very happy right now.
It's the fourth.
Uh, I did not make this prediction, but there was a psychic making a prediction that we could have, right.
They always leave the door open.
So we could have a blackout on the fourth or fifth.
Hopefully we've made it through that.
Although, you know, it's not the night of the fifth yet.
So, um, I just, you know, hopefully that's the case.
But what I have said this whole time, um, people talking about the 20th people talking about the fourth.
And I've said, um, the astrology clearly indicates that the greatest moment of danger this month is on the ninth or 10th.
And I stick with that and I will happily be wrong.
And I'll happily give a space saying, I don't know what I'm talking about.
I'm a terrible astrologer.
I picked the wrong date.
Um, but something I believe will occur.
Even if it's not a crisis and people want a date, they want like explosive events.
They want Hollywood, right?
It could just be some kind of news.
It could be an executive order.
It could be something, but there's going to be some transition at that time from people not taking what's happening seriously in the U S to taking it seriously.
After that could be the oil prices.
It could be, there's going to be some event for that, that, that activates the results of the Saturn Neptune transit at that time.
And by mid April, like we're going to be in a different headspace.
One thing I know is going to happen is that, um, the last oil coming to JP Morgan says the last oil coming to this country from Saudi Arabia during this crisis will be here on April 15th.
We don't, there's a lot of confusion about how much oil we have.
Um, people say we're energy independent.
It's not true.
They, they get that idea from the fact that we export fossil fuels.
And so what they think is, well, since we're exporting fossil fuels, therefore, if we don't export it, we add that to the amount that we have.
And now we're energy independent.
What we do export is mostly natural gas.
We are natural gas energy independent.
That's true.
We are not oil independent.
Even if people make that claim.
And the oil that we export is oil that we don't have the capacity to refine because refineries are designed for different types of oil.
So we send out oil that other countries who, who have built refineries to that type of oil, they're going to refine that.
If we keep all that oil here, we have to build a refinery or change, you know, alter our refineries in some way in order to make it so that we can, um, refine all that oil.
So even then, uh, we do get, uh, I'm, I'm spitballing here.
It's like 6%, 6% of our oil from Saudi Arabia.
Um, there will be like price increases and shortages and stuff like that.
Uh, the demand, uh, destruction from COVID was roughly around the same.
I think it was like 8%.
Um, this time, obviously it's not going to be because people all, I don't know.
It's not obvious actually.
If the UN had their way and I'm not talking to conspiracy, so I'm saying like the world's energy or the who, no, I don't know.
Some, some UN body wants people to stay home and it wants to do lockdowns in order to deal with the, the energy situation, the energy supply shock.
So that's, it's their idea.
It's not like a conspiracy thing.
Um, Europe, it looks like it's going to go along with that.
We can pretty much guess our administration won't, uh, they might want to do it through price, but losing 6% of your energy supply, even if we could cut that in half to 3%, that's still going to be enough.
The price of gas will go up high enough.
People will start to stay home.
Right.
And you'll have demand destruction.
So that is coming, um, later this month.
That is what I was concerned about.
I was concerned that the biggest news item was going to be, um, like a massive issue related to a blackout.
Um, was my number one concern.
Now I know you're saying like, oh, it should be like if a building blows up or the space shuttle blows up, that should be bigger.
No, like a, a long blackout, um, in this country with people unwilling to prepare a blackout of like three days in April when it's cold or a week in April when it's still cold at night would be catastrophic.
So I'm glad that didn't come up.
And I hope that we get to April without any blackout, uh, pray to God.
And, um, that's not an act.
The blackout is an astrological prediction.
It's from other people's remote doing work.
The only astrological prediction I'm making is that, uh, something is going to shift.
Um, something is going to occur on the 9th and 10th and it's going to be serious.
I think that the 19th is probably a secondary date.
Very well, maybe something that happens then as well.
So that's my take on the video.
Um, I think that combined, they hit some target, but I don't think individually any of them did.
I think Josh probably came closest with, um, the shuttle.
Um, but if it does end up being in the shuttle, he didn't even name it as the shuttle.
Right.
So, yeah.
Um, what are we done now?
We're the fifth in a couple hours.
That's four days away.
So I think that justified giving a short, a quick space to get it down.
Like if the information, in my perspective, contemporaneous records, we can look back in a month and say like JT, you suck.
Or we can say, oh, well, you know, actually when we target after RV projects, we should be looking at, you know, we should be looking at the methodology that, that Morgan and I developed as opposed to what these guys are doing.
Um, and maybe people will, will notice, right.
And maybe we'll, um, be able to convince them to use the methodology we developed.
I don't know, but thank you all for coming.
Does anyone have any questions before I, uh, go feed the cats?
I appreciate you coming back, Melissa and Barkley, Doc, and Cindy and I appreciate you, you joining.
Um, but thank you very much for, for doing that.
Um, guys, uh, if no one has any questions, then I'm going to, um, go feed the cats and there'll be like 15 seconds of silence before the,
before the space ends, uh, because of the lag.
So, all right, guys, have a good night.
And, uh, I'm going to run one, uh, what are we doing on Saturday?
I'm going to be back on Thursday.
Uh, but I haven't exactly decided which one I'm going to run yet.
So, I'll, I'll post that if anyone has an interest.
Um, I'll talk to you, uh, later.
I'll see you later at least.
Bye.